this is the top yup this is the top and
I okay up that's the bottom alright I
don't think I've ever spent a dime on a
bathing suit I know zero about women's
bathing suits muy caliente okay well
Sports Illustrated action you guys not
different is it how do women do it I
would not feel okay with this this is a
large are you kidding me this is two eye
patches that were sewn together look at
this stupid thing a hundred and fifty
dollars let's say twenty four dollars
for the set thirty four dollars that's
how much it is
two hundred dollars no okay so this is
good prize there's no way this is
twenty-five dollars worth of material
see this is nice got a whole Boardwalk
Empire vibe there's a triangle right
here Illuminati confirmed
forty dollars seventy-five dollars world
shut up there's a two hundred forty six
dollars for dude you're going into the
ocean or into a chlorine filled pool and
you're gonna spend almost three hundred
dollars on this why don't you just go in
your prom dress
alright you must look damn good in this
one piece do you have to buy them
separately oh my gosh this is an awesome
color scheme it's also kind of tacky I'd
say probably thirty bucks
$29 eighteen dollars woah one hundred
one hundred and two dollars this is a
hundred $2 bottle more frills there are
the more expensive it gets the young
lady who chooses this one it's a fan of
peace no I'm looking at the frilly part
in the front it's fairly soft 32 hours
say this probably cost like 40 bucks
this may be cost like 50 bucks
okay now we're in the bargain deals
right here this is cool this is one of
my favorites so far and it's like cheap
what is going on here you like put it on
like that huh
this is like an older distinguished
woman's swimsuit probably might get my
would wear this this is straight-up
Taylor Swift $85 $43 $35 I would never
spend $175 on a bathing suit okay like
maybe if it like lit up or something
cool but these aren't lined up women
they have to mix and match they have to
try to find a good deal they have to
find cute ones like it's tough in half
the time I go swimming in basketball
shorts you're beautiful the way you are
these things they're nice they're super
nice first off but expensive if paying
$100 makes you feel better in your
swimsuit then great swimsuit
manufacturers shame on you at first I
was like women are just getting screwed
by these swimsuit companies but now that
I know there's some affordable ones you
probably have these like seven different
worms for seven different days in seven
different colors and I would this is not
a large